what was a joke just a few years ago is
now steps closer to becoming reality
this week wing aviation Google's drone
delivery service was given the green
light by the FAA to start making
commercial drone deliveries within the
year the company met the agency safety
requirements by conducting thousands of
test flights in Australia and
participating in a pilot program in
Virginia as part of this pilot program
wing used an unlikely test subject
Chipotle burritos delivering them to
Virginia Tech students in 2016 I hope it
starts here and spreads you know
everywhere I think it can be a really
good idea what started as a lunchtime
delivery for college students now aims
to increase access to goods east carbon
emissions and decrease traffic
congestion the drones can carry anything
from a family's weekly groceries to
medical supplies possibly changing the
future of healthcare earlier this month
the drone delivered a donor kidney to
surgeons at the University of Maryland
who used it in a successful
transplantation doctors called it a
landmark event today we've been able to
demonstrate the power of the imagination
the future of what organ transplantation
can be I have to admit this is when I
doubted that was gonna happen but it's
amazing how I'll take this over the
flying cars yes okay okay
especially when you seek when you use
the organ donation yeah yeah incredible